the first thing probably were
publications which I saw in popular
magazines of houses of Frank Lloyd
Wright caught my eye and made me
interested in architecture the
Courvoisier was probably one of the
greatest architects of the 20th century
his work is extraordinary and as a young
architect as a student of architecture
the Courvoisier was extremely important
to me in understanding certain aspects
about architecture after i graduated
from architecture school i traveled and
visited almost all of like overseas work
accepting and accept you know it went to
accept in somewhere at any rate his
influence was very important to me as a
young person in later life it's probably
less so
you